morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast we are back and in studio
on a Tuesday morning oh my god just gave
me the weirdest luck he's used to
hearing you know sublime vocals for me
no and because he's really used to the
cadence of this show like he falls
asleep right at the goo the sweet sound
of good morning Millennials and then
when we're done and I do my bye with a
pepper by Jay he pops up it's why you
guys don't get to see it maybe we should
like leave it for a second next time
because it's crazy his biological clock
is on point with the toast and that's
just the type of leadership we have here
at toast and toast news network so happy
Tuesday everyone thank you guys so much
for being here live with us on YouTube
we are sorry about yesterday's episode
honestly it was not our fault I woke up
not feeling it and then I opened my
blinds and I was really soon the rain
was coming down sideways it was so crazy
lasted all day I'm so glad we didn't
come into the studio because we wouldn't
have been able to walk without getting
like torrential downpour it the set
would have been wet it would have been
crazy and zoom suffice there was
definitely some learnings oh by the way
for our first zoom of this quarantine I
thought it was like pretty much almost
there like there was three things I
would have changed I got would have
moved my microphone I would have given
you a microphone and I would have gotten
a bigger ring light because it looked so
ugly like maybe put on some bronzer yeah
I wish I had like a better camera
situation I think the camera on my
computer is like trash my computer is
like so light it's like the air some
sort of Mac that's just like it doesn't
have good hardware you know yeah you
know and that's the most important thing
about a computer is having a good heart
where yes and just a good camera so it
can look snatch but anyways zoom is
definitely a good backup we'll
definitely try and do more zoom episodes
sporadically just to limit the amount
that we're going out but we still feel
very comfortable with our respective
commutes you know the precautions that
we're taking yeah but it's uh it's
finally it's looking a little better in
New York spirits are high and that's
that's truly all that matters you know
yeah beer it's spirits are high I don't
know I'm just like not looking super
snacks today because I'm trying this new
thinks I feel like everyone is using
this quarantine like self care you know
hair is growing skin is glowy
beard is grow
bushes growing and I'm like I want to
give my hair the best chance best
fighting chance and so I've made the
decision to stop using heat on my hair
during quarantine because I want to use
this opportunity to get healthy hair so
my hair is just gonna be a little
different you know I think I'm I I
unintentionally did the same thing and
I'm like jealous of all these people who
like haven't ran a curling iron through
their hair in over a month and I've been
doing it almost every day and I'm done
so I'm gonna do a low bun till the end
of time I'm honestly digging the low bun
for you you know it's a low bun is so
particular because a low bun with no
part is not good a high bun with no part
is fine but a little bit but I have a
weird part like I'm afraid to tilt my
stop down because I have a I have a
cowlick let me say new you just have a
zigzag like remember those yeah it's
like from the 90s on the infomercial so
you get like a zigzag helmet liner like
it was crazy that is crazy I kind of
wanted to do that now get a zigzag ok
you should with your butterfly clips
like it's just part of your aesthetic
yeah it's totally part of my aesthetic
um anyways yeah so my hair is just like
not super cute but it's it's for the
best
it's for the best and I'm feeling
refreshed like I'm actually glad that we
decided to stay home yesterday because I
just was not feeling well at all I've
just been getting a migraine almost
every day in quarantine it's awful Wow
yeah I could pinpoint what the usually
my triggers for a migraine which I get
like maybe once a month are lack of
sleep or the weather so yesterday I had
a migraine and I always get a migraine
when it rains maybe it's lack of fresh
air I think it's just lack of like
stimulation in any sense of the word I
should give you one of my migraine pills
you could see if it works except you're
so crazy about medication yeah like you
know if I don't get prescribed a Medlock
I can't take a medication from someone
that like did it like come from a doctor
you know like my doctor such a square
I am such as where you meet all your
medications you square you guys we
didn't have the choice movie of the day
which I also loved it really are the
freedom you I personally chose movie of
the day to those who um who subscribed
to my to those who felt it was
applicable and hsm too I have so many
thoughts for the recap and then tonight
toast movie of the day is HSM 3 I'm so
excited I feel like I've only seen HSM 3
three times in my life like it's
not in Grain it's kind of like the
cheetah girls that third movie that I
kind of forgot about yeah but HSM 3 was
released in theatres no but - I think I
saw it in theaters I probably saw it
once or twice after but like I haven't
seen it over and over again like HSM 1 &
2 like I knew every single word to every
single song and I think I know all the
HSM 3 songs because they were the best
songs and I listened to them the most on
Spotify because you were older I like
forget the plot who is the villain I
don't know I'm so excited does it take
place it's their child you Asian know
they're like doing their last play while
they graduate I think Troy has like
college commitments maybe at the
University of Albuquerque and then it's
like basketball or my dreams I mean get
you a guy who can do both he needs to
learn how to balance better you know oh
by the way literally like that whole
premise is the entire premise of the
season I'm currently on a blunt real
it's like basketball and my dreams but
my girlfriend's going to UNC like it's
like so dumb and that was like the that
was the trend of like young adult movies
and TV shows in the early 2000s like do
I you know do I chase my dreams or my
dad's dream yeah even Riverdale now it's
like Archie has to choose between music
and football but then also between like
running a boxing club and not murdering
someone like it's crazy [ __ ] I haven't
been keeping up I'll be of Vanderpump
rules tonight and tomorrow is the
premiere of Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills which is just what I needed
oh and also last night song land came
back it did and the first artist was
Italy the antibellum yes oh my god I
think I'm so excited I'm so excited to
watch with my husband I was supposed to
watch like play for play with snitch but
she's watching right now oh that's rude
so she didn't catch cheating wait for me
like I wait for her and she's losing the
toes Oh watch it with Ben Ben love song
land Zak love song like that's
fascinating you guys if you're not
watching song land you ain't living
watch season 1 it's the best show ever
and if you don't like want to commit to
a whole season like you could just
choose the episodes by artist yeah like
if you are a huge you know Jonas
Brothers fan right it's you could just
choose by episode which is cool but the
best song that has come out of song land
by far is the Old Dominion episode yeah
so you'll want to watch that for damn
sure um I'm just doing like a lot of
people asking about my sweat pants yeah
you have a lot going on today and I
think from like the bottom to the top
you need to take us through your log I
just want to say like this is what it
feels like to you and it's like so
exciting I'm just like feeling like
everyone wants to be me and it's so
fabulous so my pants are toast merch
and would you want to stand up I decided
to ruin them and follow a tik-tok to
tie-dye them with bleach toilet cleaner
last night allow me to show you like not
story the tie dyeing I just didn't see
yours I did one story I didn't feel like
doing a tutorial because like when
you're worried about like filming that's
we can mess up you and also like you
can't do it tutorial because this is
your first time doing it like you're not
the expert yeah and I came to a tutorial
because I'm literally using both hands
with rubber gloves try not to get bleach
on my hands yeah no wait here these are
the toasts
I'll show you they have the champagne
glasses on the hips okay these oh these
are the toast pans she tie-dye them
herself
you have the toasting you have the
tie-dye which is like so cool love that
for you then I was just looking for
something to wear with these newfound
tiger queen sweatpants
I found this like random black I thought
that it might have been a sample for
like a merch perhaps sometimes we get
the blanks but then Ben told me he
thinks this is his sweater but I told
him it's mine now and I'm tie-dyeing it
after the toast today I wish I had time
this morning to have time to hide it
because then I could've been wearing
like a full ensemble but so this will be
the new Tiger Queen sweatshirt I'll be
tie-dyeing later today basically what
you do is you scrunch it up with some
rubber bands throw some bleach in there
for like 20 minutes rinse it out with
water and throw it in the washing
machine and then the dryer it's really
not that hard I didn't follow like a
special tutorial with like a timer you
know I just like felt it when I felt
like it was right it was time to throw
it in the wash you know understood um
and then my earrings are Margaret
Joseph's when I went to the UM Celine
Dion concert which was like my last
night out before quarantine marker
josephs was wearing these earrings and I
told her that I loved him and she said
they're shot Margaret Joseph's and she
had the messenger to my house and I
haven't like found the appropriate
occasion yet to wear him but this outfit
was so the occasion like I actually
tried on like a more demure pair of hoop
nation by Alexis and I was like should I
go like low-key I'm like influence your
hoops do you wear yes TNN podcast hosts
hoops do you wear that's what I'm saying
and you know I actually have worn those
hoop nation earrings a lot actually when
I met Kim Kardashian wore them like so
they've they've had their moment in the
Sun and I just felt like it was time for
me to be iconic ya know I think this is
everything of the sort
oh and then I did my eye shadow winged
eyeliner which is just has me feeling
like another level of snatch today yeah
it's just like your classic look now
your go-to look I'm a classic yeah
classic bougie that's something like
when you think of the classic that's how
you think I was going to say classic
like mkto classic yellow the new piece
I don't know if that was yeah that was
people but I just know there's a song
like that okay cool well Coolio thanks
for bringing your all for us today
just watch your from is that Chanel oh
yes my sweatshirt is from it's this new
online store it's called shop morning
toast calm and honestly they have the
cutest cutest stuff temporarily closed
well this is shopping merch - they're
fulfilling orders left right and center
and I'm just so excited for everyone to
get them but I told you last week like
I'm only wearing toast merch on the show
from now on I like need our toast merch
store to reopen because I need a place
to knit water I ruin these pants like I
need I need a ruined pair and then like
a regular black pair these are the best
weapons those are the best sweater are
they still in stock I think so okay
there are a few pairs left
also snitch put up her YouTube video
yesterday like the combi clothes that
she has and obviously she was a toasty
Queen but also check out her new YouTube
channel snitch in the city it's so good
it's so cute let's literally the
highlight of my day like she sends it to
me to watch and I wasn't ready and
normally like I would have just watched
it so I could like tell her that I liked
it but like I wanted the experience like
I wanted to set it up I wanted it on my
TV like I wanted a snack I wanted a
popsicle like I enjoy it so much I need
her to release content like a little bit
more I know it's so good it's so good
I'm so glad that she made that decision
on this show yeah there's just so much
content actually if you're like a part
of the TNN toast family like snitches
YouTube channel all of our new podcasts
there's no patreon so there's really no
excuse for you to be bored during this
quarantine times redheads are at 2 a
month that means two books I yesterday I
spent the day I started the redheads
book and obviously finished I heard that
it's like everyone's favorite choice
it's phenomenal it's so good I'm really
excited for the discussion we're gonna
have about it because it's just like and
I was saying this on our zoom you know
now that I'm just in my head all day
like I've really been taking a lot of
trips down memory lane and just thinking
about like my life and I feel like this
book a lot of the themes are about like
memory and time and like just how you
remember things memory in the moon right
when we read it Cosgrove sings that for
her audition in School of Rock like that
was so lame of her she like is she was
the go-to in the early 2000s if just
like you need someone lame like let's
get like teacher's pet nerds
yeah worm that movie so but she's also
Maggie
yeah well you know I've recently become
a part of the vlog squad I'm such a huge
david dobrik friend and he is friends
with Josh Peck I actually became a part
of the lock squad to Aaron and I spoke
yesterday did you what did she say she
listened to the pocket she gave me some
tips on the Zoom audio Oh what does she
start the video I've been doing their
vlogs
she said it's better like don't use the
zoom audio if we both have recorded
ourselves on the voice note app and then
put that over the video it would have
been really good that's perfect you know
advice lager it was really great advice
well I'm obsessed with the vlog squad
and David is obsessed with Drake and
Josh like it was his favorite show
growing up and he's become friends with
Josh so it's like his live stream and he
got miranda cosgrove i just i'm
rewatching all of his videos he's like
over 700 but I'm new here so I just got
to the video where he convinced miranda
cosgrove - come film vlog with him and
he surprised Josh with Meghan and it was
really iconic damn good times I feel
like everyone actually I'll save that
segue because it's time oh it is I just
made the decision that it's time I just
want to get right into it
Jackie this is a partnership like this
is 50 a.m. but you know what sometimes
you just have to go with your gut I
totally I don't need you to trust me I
better you know my trusty with me let's
go it is time for the fast eye stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast that feels good it feels right
feels right okay well I feel like people
have really been using this quarantine
to you know go down man really memory
lane you know enjoy their nostalgia I
think just you know no but like
everyone's like watching old [ __ ] yes oh
yeah yeah yeah
the High School Musical cast is
reuniting for an at-home sing-along I
heard Kenny Ortega is getting the band
back together and then with Zac Efron
I'm gonna put that in parenthesis for
now because we need to talk about that
when ABC and Bob Iger asked high school
musical director Kenny Ortega to
participate in the April 16th special
the Disney family sing-along he was
immediately on board quote I wanted to
find something I can do to participate
and it was so great to be given the call
and invited by ABC to join he told
deadline it gave me a purpose to get up
every morning I feel really good that we
have an opportunity to do something like
this it's good medicine that said he
asked actors an artist from his movies
and TV series to participate in an epic
performance of the high school musical
anthem were all on this together for the
special of the participants he wrangled
the East High Wildcats from High School
Musical and Vanessa Hudgens Ashley
Tisdale Corbin Bleu
Monique Coleman and Lucas Grabeel all
agreed to participate in one way or
another got liqueur bin' blue in the
last minute addition zac efron agreed to
come on board to send a message during
the special okay oh so he just like sent
a video from his house well here's the
thing everyone's isn't a video from
everyone's house so at first I read this
I was like there's no way they're
getting Zac Efron like I'm watching the
movies and it's like he's Ted Bundy like
he can't go back to bed I know he has
come so far like he was Link Larkin like
he is so beyond High School Musical he
has come really so far like some of the
stuff they made him do was like so
[ __ ] change and like you know what I
would have a little bit of resentment -
I'm not gonna lie but then people are
saying they got Zac Efron I just feel
like I feel like on the one hand he
won't participate because he's so above
and out on the other hand like we always
forgot that him and Vanessa Ann like
were in love but and by the way I
realized it like we said about so many
movies that's what makes the high school
musical series incredible Bella and
Edward totally they are so in love
totally Troy and Gabriella are so in
love and and I think that separates like
the boys from the men in terms of
cruises great movies we also like cuz i
was thinkin about descendants and it
doesn't have it doesn't have that love
story at the center because dub Cameron
actually dates um Captain Hook's son so
like she's with Thomas Doherty who's you
know who's a villain and because her and
King been like didn't have it I think
that's the only thing that's missing
from descendants well that's like One
Tree Hill like Chad Michael Murray and
Sophia Bush got married and divorced but
like there was a love their dads like
see ya later
that's like Gossip Girl yes you know
that's like Riverdale yes yeah no it
definitely elevates a series it elevates
a brand elevates a franchise and I don't
think that's the reason why
Zac Efron might not have participated I
don't think he's like lamenting everyday
over his breakup with Vanessa but I
think there's some awkward [ __ ] like
because I really think that they were so
serious and you don't just become
friends with that person yeah but like
she was in a relationship for like so
much has happened like I don't think
that it's awkwar-- digestion if you read
before we were strangers like it's still
married it's still there I just don't
know if Zac Efron like really wants to
be pulled back into that like he of all
the people from that series like a lot
of them are famous but he's made it
further than anyone but yeah I don't
still even think of him as a guy from
high school musical but I definitely
think of Ashley Tisdale and I definitely
think of Vanessa
as like the kids from Disney I forget
that that's where ii got started yeah he
is a very esteemed doctor like he will
win an Oscar one day yeah you know and
so I understand why he's not like
running T no tick tock with the crew you
know like I'm obsessed with his Troy's
dad Mark Johnson Oh in real life in real
life in the show like I hope they still
chat in real life Bart Johnson is
married to Blake Lively's sister so he's
in-laws with Blake Lively and Ryan right
like hey now I absolutely love that he's
very thirsty like if there's any ever
any piece of content on the internet
that it's remotely has to do with High
School Musical like Bar Johnson is the
first comment like laughs laughs laughs
okay I'm surprised he's not in high
school musical the musical the series
yet yeah because you know who is who um
I like to pop and lock
oh yeah she like she's I think you say
she's everything which she is I love her
she was great in the movies and I'm glad
that she's still working she's all over
tech chocolate really and leaning into
that High School Musical Fame what's her
name Martha Martha she's fabulous yes
she's happy this but she is in high
school musical the musical the series
there's like a school board meeting pop
lock and gym and break I didn't know she
was in this series and so happy you know
she had like one second whatever I hope
she get a paycheck and you know who's
the other cameo in the series that
doesn't know who Lucas Grabeel and it's
like no Ryan Shar Peis rather you know
to me like he was just the worst
character in notice re he was the best
character but it was really before its
time because he was obviously gay but
they like never gave him like a real
love story or like anything because I
think it one boy that even like I had
I'm hooking up with a girl no I actually
I watch ASA HSM too and I have I need to
get to the recap but even though there's
we cannot be serving up justice first
Sharpay and by the way Gabriella wasn't
just swimming and crying but she was a
little shy ste because like when she saw
that Troy and Sharpay were like playing
golf and like hanging out with like the
U of A alumni she like went to Ryan and
was like pretend flirting with him and
like she knew what she was doing she was
crafty as hell but Zoe in the two movies
that you'd watched at was Ryan ever like
dating someone
no but in HSN - I think ultimately no he
doesn't take Kelsey because
hsm - when they're they're lighting the
lanterns Kelsie's with that guy Jason
who's like such a kiss-ass but he seems
really well-meaning yes so like even
though like Ryan and Sharpay like are
really iconic like I feel as though
there was a whole element missing that
like now would have been better to
produce because like he's obviously gay
well that's like in highschool musical
in the musical the series the person who
plays Sharpay in the musical that
they're putting on at the school is a
guy and he's fat everything yep see like
that's what like Disney couldn't do back
then but I haven't seen HSM three yet
maybe they give Ryan some love yeah but
like I don't like look I just could they
could have done so much more with Ryan
like a fabulous moment for him and we
just didn't get that because I think
they were afraid to like lean into his
gayness which he was totally gay yeah no
I'll let you know tomorrow what happens
in HSM 3 I feel like there will be a
love story for him um maybe it is Kelsey
I feel like I have a very vague memory
of him being like paired up with a girl
yeah me too and it's just like so
unrealistic and there's also another
weird element which is that Ryan and
Sharpay are like a little insatiable yes
of course and obviously they get the
lead in every musical what happens with
the leads kids yes of course that's our
favorite type or they're falling in love
and I like that second thing right like
we need a prequel because before trying
Gabriella showed up like they were just
getting the leads in everything so like
they're obviously had to have been a
moment where like they were [ __ ] on
stage or something or even just like
playing lovers like that which is we're
twisted totally yeah miss darbus like
she was a little - she was a million for
my taste
okay also so the high school musical
element will be exciting and it's just
I'm excited about this because you know
people are coming together everyone's
trying to uplift people spirits but it's
like I would love this nothing more than
when they could all be at a soundstage
and [ __ ] like rip you know but okay
you know what I won't even ask for that
I'll ask can we get like them all
individually transported to individual
Studios by themselves like I just cannot
have this being from their computer any
more like their zooms are just not
cutting it like put them in a in a
totally sanitized soundstage like just
one of them at a time
oh I mean yes that you get really hung
up on the technology it's because I'm
distracted yeah I just wish I can't wait
this is such a fabulous idea like can we
please save it for one we can do it in
person listen to listen to else is
coming together in addition to the
original six from high school musical
Kenny Ortega
said that artists from the Disney family
will be coming together from many
different projects this includes Raven
Symone we worked with on Cheetah Girls
and cast members from the descendants oh
my god I have to tell councilor snitch
zombies and High School Musical musical
the series oh I thought you were gonna
say like sunny with the chance Wizards
of Waverly Place and Hannah Montana and
Jonas the performance of we're on this
together is a recent addition to the
Disney family sing-along which is um
airing on April 16th at 8:00 p.m.
eastern time on ABC this sing-along will
also feature Christina Aguilera Michael
Buble Kristin Chenoweth aloo leek
ravallo
Amber Riley John Stamos ariana grande
Demi Lovato Alan Menken Elle Fanning
Josh Groban Darren Criss Tori Kelly and
more wow wow you just wish we could have
it like in the real way that God
intended right like the was like
remember when they did the wizard wicked
like 50th anniversary yeah I got that
whole thing like in person yes I'm sort
of like gymnasium glam I would just like
can we save this amazing idea but how
come these people will only come
together in times of crisis like it's no
buts cuz they all are bored they
literally all their work has been
cancelled like they need to pay their
bills and like Disney is offering a
paycheck uh Vanessa Hudgens like has got
to pay for her Coachella tickets in
October yeah and I'm sure Vanessa
Hudgens is like eager to swiftly move on
from it she is eager to get her name in
the press for something other than her
awful rant and now like can alter her
google search a little bit yes so but I
guess this means that verdict is in
she's not cancelled no no no well that's
a good segue into one of our next one is
our next story because there are have
been a few cancellations Vanessa Hudgens
was like the leader of the pack I'm
sorry Vanessa Ann Hudgens was the leader
of the pack she was the first one to go
um and it's good to see that people have
like moved on even though I obviously
don't agree with what she said like I'm
not a proponent of canceled culture and
I'm glad that she's still she's quiet
but she's not dead for sure she said
something stupid like she said it she
knew how guys move on like it's really
not that deep what's also not that deep
erin foster defends joke about wedding
before about having a wedding before
coronavirus despite criticism I just I
absolutely love this story because she's
not backing down
Erin Foster was bashed online after she
expressed relief over having had her
wedding to Simon Hickman most months
before the coronavirus crisis so she
posted a picture from her wedding and
captioned it not too
but what a time to have already had your
wedding many people thought the post was
in poor taste one user slammed foster
saying her comment was completely
idiotic during this time when so many
have lost so much so she replied to that
comment saying this has nothing to do
with something loss yeah another
follower explained that quote a lot of
money for these people has potentially
lost for brides who had to postpone
their wedding because of the corona
virus pandemic when you have to worry
about finances it's scary not traumatic
of course by the way and not to take
away from anyone who has had to it's
definitely annoying and terrible to have
to delay your wedding it definitely
causes financial strain like it's it's
it's there's no denying that it's a bad
situation to be in
but this post has absolutely nothing to
do with anyone other than Aaron Foster
and like if we're now getting so in the
weeds on people's Instagram jokes like
that's how bored we are we're getting so
mad about this like I'm out but this is
not this is not offensive like I'm sorry
no this is not offensive but I just not
and it's not that serious and by the way
it is a great time to have already had
your wedding I mean and by the way like
am I gonna get cancelled I keep saying
like how glad I am that my tour ended in
January like the timing is so perfect
because now all these people are like
being displaced with their tickets and
I'm just like glad I'm not going through
that and it's like that's okay to be
grateful for timing right it's really
just it's not that serious whatsoever no
it's not that serious and to be honest I
feel like in this day and age whenever
anyone gets called out for anything they
just like delete it and apologize
because like that's the way they'll
survive in this business but am I kind
of down for in foster being like nila
can we just point out how dumb this is
like I totally and this is not to say
that like people whose weddings have
been affected by coronavirus like aren't
legitimate and feeling sad about that
binary post has nothing to do with you
yeah it's unbelievably stressful there
is a lot of money lost like it's it's
May and weddings are stressful and
expensive before coronavirus so like
this is just and the wedding industry
like if you own like a bakery like this
is just stressful for everyone and we
just why you might be grateful if you've
already had your wedding yeah like it's
really not that serious and like the
people who are like literally writing on
her post like writing into page six like
you just you have got to stop you have
got to get a hobby you've got to get a
hobby like and you know what if you are
offended by this joke like that's your
prerogative be offended move on now why
don't you be offended silently today I
just not I'm not here for its we're get
you guys it's getting out of control
she commented the post is still up for a
reason I stand by it there is ZERO harm
in it my wedding has nothing to do with
dramatic girls having tantrums about
their weddings it's just it's just not
what people are making it out to be and
I'm just I'm feeling now more than ever
in the age of quarantine like it's okay
to laugh about things that make you sad
so that's called a joke and I just think
we should all look it up and remember
what it is and if you don't like it
don't laugh okay yeah and I mean I think
a lot of people are getting people are
comparing this like but you know we were
against what Alan said like I think this
skit like it's so [ __ ] different by
the way I thought what Ellen said was
like not funny I wasn't really offended
by it but I just I just I just like hate
love when people talk [ __ ] about Ellen
so like I hopped on the battery Cius
but I also I think that's the jokes are
completely different in there apples and
oranges like you can't just compare
every statement you don't like to one
another yeah and like to be honest if
we're gonna really get in the weeds here
like Aaron was making a joke about
herself so she's safe like you you're
joking about other people you're making
fun of other people like that I
understand other people being offended
by it but if you're making a joke just
about yourself like literally no one has
any right to be offended yeah
like that's why I really only make jokes
about myself like I call myself fat cuz
like no one's gonna get mad at me ya
know it's it's getting wild out here you
guys I can't like I can't even believe
that I people can comment on Instagram
like crazy but I can't believe that this
is even like a story that I saw yeah and
it's like when you come and it's you
can't really compare like cancellations
because every situation is so different
but like with Vanessa Anne had an
Hodgins like what she said like was
wrong and like kind of evil like there
was look there I'm I'm not for canceled
culture but when like there's backlash
like I understand it sometimes like it's
totally warranted or it's not warranted
and to me this is just a situation where
it's totally unwarranted yeah I agree
with that and I hope that like that's
the mentality of everyone in like page
six is just like being like tabloid II
cuz that would suck like I'm sure Agron
has such a big pit like she was just
trying to share like a really cute photo
of her in her wedding dress yeah but I'm
glad that she's standing right and not
deleting it because then people just
feel more encouraged like oh we don't
like something let's yell about
Australian yeah yeah I agree okay
next story is really sad lily
Reinhardt's dog Milo is recovering after
getting attack did you see these stories
on her Instagram story like whenever
people cry about their dog like it
makes me cry so hard so lily Reinhardt
posted on her Instagram story last week
she was crying she was so sad because
her dog was attacked by another dog now
she said that Milo is resting he's
taking it easy he has some doggy CBD
that helps him kind of stay more chilled
out right now he's doing really well and
getting lots of love oh my god that was
so sad it's my worst nightmare now I
know I'm about to spark like a huge huge
controversy you know what but I'm just
curious what type of breed attacked her
because you know and by the way I know
that like there's this whole controversy
about it but whenever I've heard about
dogs just like randomly being attacked
in in parks like it's always by a pit
bull like and by the way I'm not saying
that all pit bulls are bad I'm just
saying like I'm curious to know and she
didn't say we cuz like she's so PC you
know I'm just really curious like
Kristin Jody's dog or like her friend's
dog like a few years ago was attacked by
this like vicious pit bull in a park I
don't know I'm gonna get so many gems
about this because it's like a really
hot button issue but I'm just curious
really I'm not sure this margin [ __ ]
like it doesn't matter like other dogs
attack dogs that aren't pit bulls but
I'm genuinely like just curious have you
seen the meme of like this it's like a
fire burning like a house is on fire and
it's like wow people runs back into the
fire to attack one funny oh my god no I
have never seen that name oh my god it's
so funny let's post it other it's like
see so yeah no I totally understand like
the pit bull controversy like you can't
just like you know vilify the breed it's
like it's stereotyping for dogs I
totally get it but just like I'm
genuinely curious like what kind of job
because she didn't say and usually don't
say because I can't Wow okay are you
ready for every people who sharing
stories I was attacked by a golden
retriever when I was a kid my dog was
attacked by a pug okay okay yeah I feel
I just when I hear about it
people but like maybe that's because
it's the pitbull media like trying to
stop the breeding of pit bulls maybe
that's maybe I'm just a victim in all
this
maybe you are okay are you ready for our
next story or do you want to keep
digging no I just um I just wanted to
see what people were saying like are
people mad at me I don't know I think
people are are laughing Oh another girl
was attacked by golden retriever maybe
those retrievers are problematic all I
just say is you know what I'm not gonna
say what I was about to say I was going
to jinx myself okay next story a little
breakup news lil hoodie and Charlie
D'Amelio have called it quits
they both posted on their Instagram
story and I'll read you charlie
statement because I do not comment okay
are you ready for Charlie and Lil yeah
okay by the way I saw this like
plastered everywhere this morning
because like one there's nothing else
going on and - it's like kind of a big
deal
what's crazy is there's nothing else
going on but like I I have their
statements from their Instagram stories
but I was gonna pull up a news story
about it and I didn't see one place
right now because literally the media is
so busy writing about Aaron Fosters like
nonsensical Instagram post and not the
real media news like this is important
what were their statements okay Charlie
hey guys since you guys have watched
mine and chases relationship from the
start well she decided to like dignify
him and call him chase I decided I
needed to tell you that all that we are
no longer together it hurts me to say
this but we've decided that this is
what's best for both of us we are still
close me too and I'm reading people's
comments and like it's so funny it's
died by a poodle some funny people
getting attacked obviously it's just
like a poodle honey Olivia is attacked
by a pug once remember oh my god hardly
he like snapjet her inky Meg nicked her
income that's so funny we are still
close friends and I would not change
that for anything I truly have so much
left to chase and wish nothing but the
best for him it makes me so happy to see
all the great things he has going for
him I'm sorry I waited too long to tell
you all oh they've been working while I
wanted to take the time to process it
for myself breakups are tough for anyone
so I'd really rather not talk about it
anymore
I mean legacy scenes yes same but
they're just like so young but at the
same time like I'm watching One Tree
Hill and like they're 17 years old and
like they're acting like it's the true
love of their lives like some of them
are getting married like it's like but
these are
school relationships like we're like you
hold him and like you don't talk in the
hallways like it's hard for me they're
like figure out when people are so young
like if these are what are the Bahamas
together yeah totally but there was
definitely a parental chaperone for sure
but like that's intense
- I'm sure with your 15 year old
boyfriend I don't know where the two of
them ended up I'm like the whole hype
house like split there was a whole
divide that who ended up on what side I
think that definitely had something to
do with their breakup but also like
Charlie's a star and like Lil hoody is
just like nothing of the sort
so they were they were bound to be torn
apart just by their levels of like Fame
yeah just like she is on her way to
becoming like a truly a global icon and
he's nothing of the sort
um I think maybe she like did like him
and enjoy his company um but I think she
is like big dream yeah like this is just
the type of guy like you date like very
briefly on the way up and then in five
years you're like embarrassed by you
know yeah and you know I'm sure it was
like her first relationship yeah like
I'm gonna say something so disgust I
didn't say you're gonna say but like
she's 15 so that's like oh she I thought
she was 17 yes or she's 16 no I think
you're right she's 15 so like don't say
what you were gonna yeah no I'm not you
know we already said this the pitbull
stuff yeah that's enough for one day
yeah I think I agree um anyways I hope
that Charlie like finds love our just
like who do we ship her with Jacob
Sartorius no no honestly like I know
there's such an age difference I'm like
it's so inappropriate but like a tick
tock oh I just absolutely love his Jason
Derulo that's like so it's so in a more
real like I think he's so much older
than her but I just think tick tock is
and I was talking about this with Ben
it's such a great platform for a lot of
people and it's a terrible platform for
a lot of people too and jason Derulo's
just really shining on the app like he
oh my gosh f dancing videos love they're
so good
I can't recommend to follow enough I
can't recommend enough I totally agree
our third the final story um typically
would not be chosen as a story because
she has been Chyna she is the Chyna
yes incredible I'm the biggest news day
ever like we're definitely gonna still
talk about this it's the craziest thing
ever blac Chyna has been criticized for
900 for charging nine hundred and fifty
dollars for FaceTime calls and two
hundred and fifty dollars for Instagram
follows like on her merch store she's
like selling like did
like things yeah like some people sell
presets yeah blac Chyna's selling
Instagram follows and you know what I'm
really tempted to buy one because I just
want to see if she unfollowed you after
like who's to say where's the contract
you could spend $250 she'll follow you
and then in a month she'll unfollow you
yeah that's just not a good business
deal in my opinion I am oh the 31 year
old lash Cosmetics owner Wow page six is
being super kind today what would you
say and and and former Robin China
reality star
wow that's both so nice it's so
flattering I would say blac chyna woman
who had child out of spite with with Rob
Rob Kardashian or honestly I would say
blac Chyna Rob I would say I would say
blac chyna dreams mom oh that's good - I
would say blac chyna kris Jenner's
former future daughter-in-law blac Chyna
nay Angela Renee Kardashian no I would
say a blac Chyna are you still texting
[ __ ] yes or no yeah that's the one
that's the one she is charging 950
dollars it's been a while nine inch
fifty dollars for a virtual chat with
her on FaceTime in 252 follow a fan back
on Instagram both via her business
website fans were on me unable to pay
the cash upfront have the option of
doing so with four interest-free
installments about success after paid
naturally Chyna who is an ongoing
custody battle with ex Rob Kardashian is
being called out for her newfound
business venture oh my god wait that's
insane me someone person wrote on
Twitter this woman has officially hit
rock bottom at blac Chyna's selling a
follow back for 250 and a FaceTime call
for nineteen fifty and there's a payment
available you can't make this [ __ ] up I
just want to say like if you're spending
$900 on a FaceTime with blac Chyna and
you need to do after pay like you really
need to be spending your money elsewhere
no but also if you're spending $150 on a
FaceTime call with blac Chyna and you're
not using the after may like you have
too much money oh by the way sorry I
totally you're so right also it because
I think a think of it like cameo on the
app like even big celebrity is like only
charge like the max I've seen is like
500 hours maybe a thousand and like blac
chyna it's like not that fame was like
Daymond John is on there I think he
charges a thousand like for charity
like yeah so I don't know who got tried
I think she is is in charging $900
because essentially a face
just a cameo but then do you get her
phone number no she probably does it
through like an app where or maybe like
Skype yeah you know when you got her
email address or something what do you
think she talks about she is looking so
strange these days like her like her
cosmetic procedures are just really out
there
I honestly wouldn't know I don't follow
I don't keep up you know what will be
interesting to see after this quarantine
like who use this like major downtime to
get like major cosmetic surgery even
though like most hospitals are being
forced to like postpone you think lucky
dress what get cosmetic surgery right
now well that's what I'm saying I'm sure
like major celebrities guys yeah and
also like really prestigious doctors
have their own operating rooms in their
offices so you don't have to go to a
hospital right everything working
- like postponed like Jennifer Eden's
husband was explaining how like people
are don't understand why he's been
working so much because he's a plastic
surgeon but he says like most of what he
does like reconstructive so he's been
being used in hospitals and so I thought
oh oh interesting yeah and that's the
other thing like Plastic Surgeons
because they are doctors like I'd be
lending their talents to the crisis and
Bill Aydin man of my dreams is of course
he is cuz he's the man of my dreams
exactly interesting yeah I don't know
how that would work like maybe a few of
the biggest celebs would be using this
time would be really a great time to get
your search
I left totally phase left but we'll see
I'm like it's gonna be interesting I'll
come out you know yeah like who's like
you know frown lines are sagging and
whose or not yeah my forehead is wild
and now my friend I mean I have
parentheses they're actually getting
really bad I just like hate that there's
another thing on my face that I like
want to touch because forever it was
just like just my chin and then it was
like just my chin in my eyebrows now
it's like just my chin my eyebrows and
my lips and now like I have another
thing but they're really bothering me
like my smile lines are so bad like my
makeup gets like caught up in the
wrinkles I want to get something that
would just like turn my frown upside
down a little bit you know like you just
need to watch the episode of the morning
coats I just feel like sometimes like my
resting face is a little too frowny and
it's not bad right now but I feel like
when I'm older like I'll just look like
grimace see ya know I've just especially
during this quarantine I have really
drove headfirst into and my nightly
routine like I think it's so important
and I was using a neck cream that I ran
out of and I got so many recommendations
to use this drive act in one and it was
a hundred dollars but I really wanted do
I have such bad
wrinkles in my neck interesting it's
supposed
to tighten and lift allegedly but and
when I got it like it was not like a
cream that I'd ever seen it was
literally yellow clay like it's crazy
and I'm really using a lot of is it
helping I've only been on it for like
three days but I've been on a neck cream
for like three months
they like my dermatologist said it takes
a really long time to start working but
it's like the best thing you could do
for a young person cuz they went in and
I was like can I get filler in my neck
like help me and she said definitely
start with a cream see if it does I
don't know I should have taken before
pictures maybe I'll take one now should
i starting that cream that was here
actually have a really nice nap yeah but
so you might as well preserve it yeah
cuz you said it's preventative and I'm
all about presentation I know I've had
lines in my neck like since I was in
high school yeah yeah yeah remember I
used to tan and get like these weird
lines some people are just neck line
people it's it's the worst kind of
person to be yeah I'm actually not one
of those people but I have like all my
other problems you know yeah but that's
a really good problem to not have I
wouldn't know cuz like when you're older
your neck is like a real telltale sign
of your age that's true but you know I'm
just gonna age like a raisin whatever
I'm just like I I care right now but I
have a feeling I'm like five years I'm
just not gonna care I don't know about
that but I feel like at it I don't know
we'll see let's dive into our TV recap
segment because I didn't watch it but
Jackie did watch High School Musical 2
and I know a bunch of people watched it
along with her and after watching the
first one what were your thoughts this
was one where they went to the country
club this is one where they went to the
country club and I just want to say like
they did such a good job at finding a
plot for a sequel that wasn't too
similar to the first but not so
dissimilar and I absolutely loved the
setting of lavasprings Country Club like
I would love to go there did it make you
just like want to get a house in a
country club gated community everything
wants me makes me want to get a house in
the country club data community so this
is specially did but it looked like very
humid and hot and also like everyone had
just discovered spray tans on the set so
like they're all kind of orange and they
like match the mountain and like yeah
very Orange Mexico was like not my ideal
climate but but the whole movie really
had like a Jackie O flow vibe she went
you know like super saturated and green
and blue and orange and I loved that for
that I'm so glad um the movie in general
is good but it's very conflicting
because obviously we now are of the
mindset like justice for Sharpay in the
first movie Sharpay's really not the
villain she is just like a character
with her own agenda who's kind of gets
in the way of trying Ariela but like she
has her perhaps she's determined but
what happens in the
second movies it's the last day of
school she's standing by her locker and
she walks by and she just has an
epiphany and she's like well who would
you say is that she says to Ryan who
would you say is the number one guy in
this in this group okay yes number one
guide school he said try and she said
who's the number one girl at school and
Ryan said you of course and she said so
wouldn't it make sense for us to be
together honestly that's pretty good
logic No and so the whole movie is her
trying like we'll introduce him because
she thinks that they should be together
cuz he's number one and she's number one
whereas in the first movie she had
absolutely no romantic interest in
Manado
at all mind you now in the second movie
like he he's in a very serious
relationship like not only is she
thirsty she's a home wrecker right she
has no like respect for their
relationship and she's using all of her
privilege to try and win him over and
it's just like I just don't think she
has honorable intentions and I don't
think she deserves any chances she is
really a piece of work the way that she
treats the staff at the Country Club is
so abhorrent like she makes all of the
people who work there at their jobs so
much more she literally tells Fulton to
make them want to quit huh it's crazy ya
know that's not good like she could be
using like her standing her social
standing for such good and then she also
does that like very weird is it in the
second movie where she does that who no
one uh yes like cultural appropriation
but you see my video on my Instagram no
because I literally feel mad I said this
was a low point for her yeah it wasn't
it cut out it was like an extra yes so
this is what happened it was a deleted
scene but the song still made it on the
soundtrack so everyone who the song but
I had never seen the scene
I guess Disney Plus decided to be shy
see cuz they were like all this justice
for Sharpay we don't like it you're
gonna see the movie we wait the way we
intend yeah and honestly that scene is
transformative because she's being crazy
and she like is so quick to throw her
brother in the trash
yes everyone treats Ryan like he's
nothing like he's yesterday's garbage
and Ryan has been nothing but so
supportive of her and like inflates her
ego and just does what she needs like
gets her those towels imported from
Turkey and that Turkey important
information tabulous if Brian wasn't
there setting it all up behind the scene
and then also she's like critiquing his
notes like I want Morton it's like
honestly this is enough yeah Diana yeah
just doesn't have that day a new
mentality and I can't relate wait really
quickly like total random tangent but
from that Hawaiian thing just reminded
me that I spent absolutely all day
listening to your corns Dean's playlist
and I'm so sorry that like you've been
telling me about it for a week and I
just like didn't listening you know I
just wasn't ready to like listen to new
music but I didn't realize that you had
put together like a playlist that was
gonna change my life and I'm really like
I'm so sorry for doubting you and I
listened to it and that beautiful
rendition of somewhere over the rainbow
came on which is my favorite and I just
looked up and the artwork is quite
striking because it's the back of the
singer Israel like couldn't go something
I'm sorry nothing and it's just like I
don't know what inspired me just like do
like um research on them cuz I just
remember I know that he passed away
because he was like morbidly obese and I
just like I just I don't know what that
compelled me to google his name maybe is
this his name being Israel like it's
just not something you see every day so
I went and I just like was reading all
about him and he was like so so fabulous
like did you know that when he died that
literally the entire state of Hawaii put
their flags at half-mast which they only
do for politicians and three in the
history of the of the country only three
people have gotten that honor who
weren't politicians and one of them was
Israel Wow okay Jewish no I don't know
why his name was Israel but he was just
like a he's a middle name yeah he was
just like a huge part of like the
Hawaiian music culture and like I didn't
even realize and that song like always
makes me cry partly because like the guy
who's singing it is so cute and it's
just like such a fabulous rendition it's
a fabulous addition I'm glad you finally
have their respect for the corn seems
playlist and to be honest I'm glad like
Israel did not up to see shar-pei like
disgracing his his homeland no I'm I'm
so so glad for that um also the movie is
tough because Troy's getting all these
opportunities like networking you're
playing with the alumni of U of A and
it's like his friends are like yo could
you ask him if we could come in that's
not how this works
it's [ __ ] every man for themself when
it comes to getting a college
scholarship and like his friends really
don't they keep saying he's changed and
it's like because he's wearing new shoes
but he's still that same guy and I feel
like I really felt for him because
obviously he can't spend time swimming
with Gabriella if he's going to like
network with the U of A alumni
and I just don't know what he could have
done better to manage his time and it's
like he shouldn't be throwing away his
future his dad really gave him a good
advice but he was just in a really weird
position and I think I don't I don't
know and then at the end when when
Sharpay's like you're throwing away your
future and he's just like I just care
what my friends think of me and it's
like that line wasn't like strong enough
like you should care more about like
your future than what your friends think
of you yeah no odyssey sounds a lot like
where I'm at in One Tree Hill like
they're all seniors like a lot of them
oh but like none of them are really good
enough to get scholarship also Zac Efron
is short like I don't get it
Oh Nathan Scott happens to be like 6
feet tall and like he really does he is
he looks like a giraffe like his neck is
so long like he looks a lot like um like
a real basketball player which I
appreciate it but Ben can't watch
because Chad Michael Murray is like
supposed to meet just as good as like
Nathan Scott even though he has like
this heart condition so he can't really
play but then like watches he's like
literally he's the worst basketball
player like he has absolutely no form
and like when when he shoots like the
shows chef Chad Michael Murray then they
show like another shot because he
obviously did not make the shot like
yeah Ben literally can't watch him play
he says he's the worst basketball player
I'm Hannah that's really funny yeah but
I can't buy that I'm limited in to how
many episodes I can watch now because
Ben won't can't watch during the day and
I'm not allowed to watch that I'm like
he is obsessed with the show we just got
we finished season three last night we
just got like such a good place we're
like Dan found out okay so basically
spoiler alert Dan it's like this evil
guy and someone tried to kill him and he
thought it was his brother so he ended
up like really like for the first time
ever like he killed someone like he's a
bad guy but he found a murderer but he
killed his brother because he thought
his brother did it but then this episode
he found out it was actually his wife
who tried to kill him and he's been like
feeling so guilty about killing his
brother like he's been having these
nightmares but like he feels justified
because his brother tried to kill him
but now we found out that his brother
didn't actually try to kill him it was
his ex-wife and now I feel like he's
gotta do something crazy because like
the guilt has been getting to him and
now he knows that he killed him for no
reason yeah yeah it's a really good show
I'm really enjoying it and like I just
I'm working so hard on getting snitch to
watch it I think I'm chipping away at
the stubborn it's like just a little bit
every day like yesterday I got her to
agree she said I'm not in a place where
I can take on a whole new show I'm like
that's fine but like when you are in a
place will you at least consider it and
she said yeah okay that's progress
that's progress
okay so our toes movie of the day for
those of you who are on this journey
with me and very timely because of the
April 16 special we are watching High
School Musical 3 tonight I'm so excited
I'm so excited for you guys
like usually I've been starting that
would be like after midnight and then
just falling asleep like a 2:00 a.m. but
I think tonight I might even watch like
in the afternoon because I just can't
wait we also have better from rules
tonight which I'm just like so over
regular TV anytime I have to change my
input back to cable so like put on shots
of sunset even though it's so good I'm
just like not in the mood
yeah same I'm also gonna watch song land
also bachelor listen to your heart
premiered last night the snacks are is
recapping this snatcher will have all of
the tea I can't be bothered I cannot be
bothered like usually if I'm not
watching something bad sure related and
they see stuff on Twitter like I feel
kind of left out but literally I've
never been so happy to be left out like
the show is just not and I heard it's
good and I'm so happy for everyone is
watching it I'm just not interested but
if you are looking for a recap it'll be
on the snatchler podcast tomorrow um
there's also new episodes of all of your
favorite Tina and podcasts coming out
this week so make sure you're following
Aptos news network for all those updates
that's what we got for you guys thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast the Millennial morning show where
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
for also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so it Spotify
iTunes stitcher Public Radio I have
renewal cast back so all the places
where ever you listen to podcast find us
the morning toast at leave a five star
review about our beautiful setting and
smart we are we love you guys so much
we'll see ya tomorrow
bye look at the video we could do look
at God
you